я капот бат і прадіди загального знаю з
знаходитесь його кретин нам потрібно шанс
ну і душа коротка фраза ми ж перемога
танабата нікитою на на обох
тривожний поясн це ще за руку нашої
україні вина алла наша армія зуб мене і
всі сили врага робота акцент наша армія
душа сина поясні ти сигнали сирени коли
ти чуєш чари на означаючи ще наша
армія час чого навоював вона б спайку і
бор і приватні та c що означає про нашу б
зможу додати треба запам'ятають і дитину
ще за раз ми встигнемо і кислого нам
обороту та отрути високий я-то базах шукаю я з
тобою у нас yabla я знаю чиї роботи так
ви знижки людей розум і як наша армія
нас захищаючи не асурам це за страх
дозволяє виявлятися бутики і сечі
немає ревниво ти жінки на поки woder і
ти ти молодець ти так гарна справляєшся
ти не герой ти моя охорона
переміщається укриття взяту собою
іграшку від шейн шину cue люблю ну rich 6
худоби руку огляд бат мистецтву мотанки
proceed та dtn ще більше мило нас є
нами ціна роботи будете вправо ще ззаду
у тіла праворуч на розтягування
потягування то ян чи можна бути остина
бюро тис і остін риба спрямовувати руди
піни з трубою тою в клас і кіст арбату
можна судити чим на мережах дат гру в
телефоні плитки може диском силва тис
його нога ти всього садить afterparty
дорогі з xposed в пори ти зараз
набрав у роті та ти їм конкретні
порушення та дати чоловіка весь правил
цією сечею важливі у розум з pivot та та
треба ти дати йому жив і дуже ливани
або плані складу не мого трансформу
ватою св страх і направо а я в цій
собою сім'ю mist окраїну пересилання знову
захисним куполом мальва 3 ст варівати а
я за це дроблення підручних матеріалі
за хрящі не просто я всі дати на блюдо
різкою дме вона рогою на контакт росте
і рук і мочки в так ти шоколад і солодкий
чорний чай взяті на руки пах це ти вчать
з пива ти пісню ягудин по мені то я
зультати синаєм я каже і мама-то ту
пору путін дати shooter 3 ст на телефоні
обидва міста в дартс обидва групи
в'їзну з просто новим стрибком team mи
обидва скронь у пороємося ми дуже say